This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. It's a Friday evening at an apartment in Lower Manhattan. Two friends are looking forward to unwinding after a long week. Their names are Ansel Shoal and Mateas Corona. And they can teach us all something about friendship. They've been friends for half their lives. Like seven years. No, because of its second grade, third grade, fourth grade,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是一个周五的傍晚，地点是曼哈顿下城的一间公寓。两个朋友正期待着在一周忙碌的工作后放松一下。他们叫安塞尔·肖尔和马特亚斯·科罗纳。他们可以教我们一些关于友谊的道理。他们做朋友已经半辈子了。大概七年吧。不对，因为是从二年级、三年级、四年级开始的，
fifth grade, sixth grade, seventh grade, six years. Yeah, six years, sorry. Doing the math? That means they're now 12. And like ever since second grade, we've been close friends. By fourth grade.
五年级、六年级、七年级，六年了。对，六年，抱歉。算算看？这意味着他们现在12岁了。从二年级开始，我们就一直是好朋友。到了四年级。
I mean, I knew that this is gonna be my best friend. Their best friendship has involved doing lots of homework together. Video games. We FaceTime. We help each other. He helps me. my best friend. Their best friendship has involved doing lots of homework together, video games, sleepovers like the one they're going to have tonight and legos. When they're not doing homework or playing together, the two friends are supporting each other. So my great-great-for-the-died, like a few weeks ago, he really helped me like, sort of like get through that. I came up and I'm so sorry to hug them.
我的意思是，我知道他会是我最好的朋友。他们最好的友谊包括一起做很多家庭作业。玩电子游戏。我们视频通话。我们互相帮助。他帮助我。我最好的朋友。他们最好的友谊包括一起做很多家庭作业、玩电子游戏、像今晚这样的留宿聚会，还有玩乐高。当他们不写作业或一起玩耍时，这两个朋友会互相支持。比如我曾祖父几周前去世了，他真的帮我度过了难关。我走过去，我很抱歉地拥抱了他们。
I don't know if I did it again, but I do recall saying it sometimes, not trying to be braggier, showing like, oh, so amazing, but yes, I remember being there for him. Ansel and Matthias don't think their friendship will change when they get to high school. I'm pretty sure we'll stay. Best friends. Yeah, as long as it's like, neither of us move high schools, I think we will. And why would they think differently? They have the kind of friendship that most kids, or adults for that matter, would want. But for many young men just a few years older than Ansel and Mateus, friendships like this
我不知道我是否又做了，但我确实记得有时会说出来，不是为了炫耀，表现得好像“哦，太棒了”，但确实，我记得我一直陪伴着他。安塞尔和马特亚斯不认为他们上高中后友谊会改变。我很确定我们会一直是最好的朋友。是的，只要我们俩不去不同的高中，我想我们会一直这样。他们为什么会往别处想呢？他们拥有大多数孩子，甚至成年人，都渴望的那种友谊。但对于许多只比安塞尔和马特亚斯大几岁的年轻人来说，这样的友谊
are a distant memory. Some of the boys go into, sort of, I don't care, it doesn't matter, but they say I don't care so many times that you sense exactly that they do very much care. By the time boys become men, they may not have any friends around, clothes or otherwise. It was just the sense of isolation, but the end of the day it was just me. Many men find there's no one around them at the end of the day, and they find they have become trapped by a series of unspoken rules. If you're a man, you're supposed to be strong and independent. If you connect deeply, especially with other men, it's probably because you're gay.
已成为遥远的记忆。有些男孩会表现出一种“我不在乎，无所谓”的态度，但他们说“我不在乎”的次数太多了，以至于你能感觉到他们其实非常在乎。当男孩长成男人时，他们可能身边没有任何朋友，无论是亲密的还是其他的。那只是一种孤独感，但归根结底，只有我一个人。许多男人发现，到头来身边空无一人，他们发现自己被一系列不成文的规则困住了。如果你是个男人，你就应该坚强独立。如果你建立了深层的联系，尤其是与其他男性，那很可能是因为你是同性恋。
If you crave deep, emotional bonds, well, that's just unmannedly. Today on Hidden Brain we take a closer look at misguided notions of masculinity in the United States and we explore new research that studies the consequences, stressed out romantic relationships, physical health problems, and a growing epidemic of loneliness. To understand what's going on today we need to step back 80 years and tell a story that's been passed down and even mythologized. In the late 1930s, a retail store magnet named WT Grand had a question. Can you predict who's going to become a good department store manager? To find out, he teamed up with a Harvard professor named Arley Bach and gave him $60,000 to run a study.
如果你渴望深厚的情感纽带，嗯，那是不够男人的表现。今天在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将仔细审视美国对男子气概的误解，并探讨研究这些后果的新成果：压力重重的浪漫关系、身体健康问题以及日益严重的孤独流行病。为了理解今天发生的事情，我们需要回溯80年，讲述一个代代相传甚至被神话的故事。20世纪30年代末，一位名叫WT·格兰特的零售业大亨提出了一个问题。你能预测谁会成为优秀的百货公司经理吗？为了找到答案，他与哈佛大学教授阿利·巴克合作，给了他6万美元进行一项研究。
Dr. Arley Bach thought that medical research focused too much on what made people sick. He wanted to know what made people healthy. To answer that question, and presumably WT Grants question about department store managers, he and his colleagues picked a group of Harvard students to track closely over time. After that question, and presumably WT Grant's question about department store managers, he and his colleagues picked a group of Harvard students to track closely over time. They chose 268 students, mostly from the classes of 1942, 43, and 44. The researchers thought the study would run a decade or so. All the volunteers were men.
阿利·巴克博士认为医学研究过于关注导致人们生病的原因。他想知道是什么让人保持健康。为了回答这个问题，也为了回答WT·格兰特关于百货公司经理的问题，他和同事们挑选了一组哈佛学生进行长期跟踪研究。在那个问题之后，大概也是为了回答WT·格兰特关于百货公司经理的问题，他和同事们挑选了一组哈佛学生进行长期跟踪研究。他们选择了268名学生，大多来自1942、1943和1944届。研究人员认为这项研究只会持续十年左右。所有的志愿者都是男性。
Harvard didn't admit women at the time. All were men. Harvard didn't admit women at the time. All were white. Some students went on to have distinguished careers beyond department store management. One became a swashbuckling newspaper editor. Ben Bradley not only helped the Washington Post break news, he was the news. Any story about the post must begin with Benjamin Crown and Shield Bradley.
哈佛大学当时不招收女性。所有人都是男性。哈佛大学当时不招收女性。所有人都是白人。一些学生在百货公司管理之外拥有了杰出的职业生涯。其中一位成为了敢作敢为的报纸编辑。本·布拉德利不仅帮助《华盛顿邮报》发布新闻，他本身就是新闻。任何关于《邮报》的故事都必须从本杰明·克朗·希尔德·布拉德利开始。
52. It's fast-talking,ing chain-smoking cocky executive editor. Another began president. We choose to go to the moon and disdicate and do the other thing, not because they are easy, but because they are hard. Others had hard lives and struggled with mental illness or alcoholism. As part of the study, these men were put through all kinds of tests. Researchers measured everything from the size of their moles to the lactic acid their bodies released after 5 minutes on a treadmill.
52岁。他是一位说话快、烟不离手、傲慢的执行编辑。另一位成为了总统。我们选择去月球并做其他事情，不是因为它们容易，而是因为它们很难。其他人则生活艰辛，与精神疾病或酗酒作斗争。作为研究的一部分，这些人接受了各种各样的测试。研究人员测量了一切，从他们痣的大小到在跑步机上跑5分钟后身体释放的乳酸。
The men were asked to interpret raw shark inkplots. Their handwriting was analyzed. Examiners took detailed measurements of their skulls. At the time, researchers thought the size and shape of a head could tell you a great deal about a person's character and abilities. So we now have a whole set of elaborate skull measurements that we have no idea what to do with. This is Robert Waldinger. He's the current director of the project.
这些人被要求解读罗夏墨迹测验。他们的笔迹受到了分析。检查人员对他们的头骨进行了详细测量。当时，研究人员认为头部的形状和大小可以告诉你很多关于一个人的性格和能力的信息。所以我们现在有一整套复杂的头骨测量数据，却不知道该拿它们怎么办。这是罗伯特·沃尔丁格。他是该项目的现任负责人。
It's now called a Harvard study of adult development. It's lasted far longer than Arleigh Bach and WT Grant imagine. It's now been running for eight decades. The length of the study isn't the only thing that's unusual. Its aims were hazy. Sure, it was supposed to look broadly at who does well. But research studies are often designed
它现在被称为“哈佛成人发展研究”。它的持续时间远超阿利·巴克和WT·格兰特的想象。它已经进行了八十年。这项研究的长度并不是唯一不寻常的地方。它的目标很模糊。当然，它本意是广泛地观察谁能过得好。但研究通常是为了
to test one or two specific questions. The aims of this study were nebulous and they changed repeatedly over the years. Sometimes we've been called the biggest fishing expedition in the history of research. As the years went by the studies agenda changed as new funders swept in and science evolved. The links between mind and body became more of a concern in the 1980s and 90s. One thing the study paid attention to from the very start was the volunteer social and emotional lives.
测试一两个具体问题而设计的。这项研究的目标很模糊，而且多年来反复变化。有时我们被称为研究史上最大的“捕鱼式考察”。随着岁月的流逝，随着新的资助者加入和科学的发展，研究议程也发生了变化。身心之间的联系在20世纪80年代和90年代变得更加受关注。研究从一开始就关注的一件事是志愿者的社交和情感生活。
Arleigh Bach was prescient in that way. He had a psychiatrist on his team and there were extensive interviews about the young men's emotional lives. Also, some personality assessments and some assessments of their emotional reactivity. So, all the way along, emotional well-being and personality characteristics were a subject of interest. From the studies earlier days, all the men were asked a deceptively simple question, who would you call in the middle of the night if you were sick or afraid? Who would you call in the middle of the night if you were sick or afraid?
阿利·巴克在这方面很有远见。他的团队里有一位精神科医生，并对这些年轻人的情感生活进行了广泛的访谈。此外，还有一些人格评估和情绪反应评估。所以，一直以来，情感健康和人格特征都是研究关注的主题。从研究早期开始，所有男性都被问到一个看似简单的问题：如果你生病或害怕，半夜你会给谁打电话？如果你生病或害怕，半夜你会给谁打电话？
It turned out that men who had someone to turn to were happier with their lives and their marriages. There were also connections between the men's answers to that question and their physical health. Very strong connections. That was one of the surprising things that began to emerge in our data in the 80s. We found that people who had warmer, closer connections lived longer, developed the diseases of middle age, those chronic diseases less soon and had better
事实证明，那些有求助对象的人对生活和婚姻更满意。这些人的回答与他们的身体健康之间也存在联系。非常紧密的联系。这是我们在80年代的数据中开始出现的令人惊讶的事情之一。我们发现，拥有更温暖、更亲密关系的人寿命更长，患中年疾病（那些慢性病）的时间更晚，并且平均而言比没有温暖亲密关系的人拥有更好的
health longer on average than people who didn't have warm close relationships. Warm close relationships. Now, it's easy to see why social ties might be important to happiness, but hard disease, Robert was skeptical. At first, we didn't believe our data. Then he discovered other studies were finding the same thing. This relationship between physical health
健康状况。温暖亲密的关系。现在，很容易理解为什么社会联系对幸福很重要，但心脏病呢？罗伯特起初持怀疑态度。起初，我们不相信我们的数据。后来他发现其他研究也发现了同样的事情。这种身体健康
and social connections is an obvious to most of us. When we think about how to keep ourselves healthy, we might think about eating right and getting exercise. We don't ask whether we've set aside enough time for friendships. And yet you could notice it in moment to moment interactions during the day. Think about how coming into work and seeing people you like being with is energizing. Think about the experience of being upset about something and then talking to a friend or a family member who listens well and you can feel
与社会联系之间的关系对我们大多数人来说并不明显。当我们考虑如何保持健康时，我们可能会想到饮食均衡和锻炼。我们不会问自己是否为友谊留出了足够的时间。然而，你可以在白天的点滴互动中注意到这一点。想想看，上班时见到你喜欢的人是多么令人振奋。想想当你对某事感到沮丧时，与一位善于倾听的朋友或家人交谈，你能感觉到
your body literally calm down. And so I think that if we actually take the time to notice at a microscopic level, you can notice how relationships can be both energizing in a positive way and calming when we're stressed. The study also found that bad relationships can magnify physical pain and that close relationships buffer us from the physical problems we face as we age. The researchers found that the happiest people in retirement are those who actively work to replace colleagues
你的身体确实平静了下来。所以我认为，如果我们真的花时间在微观层面去观察，你就能注意到人际关系既能以积极的方式激发活力，也能在我们感到压力时起到安抚作用。研究还发现，糟糕的人际关系会放大身体疼痛，而亲密关系则能缓冲我们随着年龄增长所面临的身体问题。研究人员发现，退休后最幸福的人是那些积极努力用朋友取代同事的人。
with friends. Today, the study focuses on this question. How is it that the quality of your relationships with your coworkers, with your friends, your family could get into your body? By today's standards, the demographics of the study were wildly imbalanced. As I said, the volunteers were all white, all men. Not just that. Most students came from well-to-do families. The research became a little more representative in the 1970s when the study of Harvard men was paired with a separate study happening in Boston.
今天，这项研究聚焦于这个问题：你与同事、朋友、家人的关系质量是如何影响你的身体的？以今天的标准来看，这项研究的人口统计数据极其不平衡。正如我所说，志愿者全是白人，全是男性。不仅如此。大多数学生来自富裕家庭。这项研究在20世纪70年代变得更具代表性，当时哈佛男性的研究与波士顿进行的另一项研究结合在了一起。
That research focused on boys from some of the poorest, toughest areas of the city. Together, these studies provide a vivid picture of men's health over the course of their lives. Now, you could say this research is obviously incomplete because it leaves out more than half the population. But it does tell a striking story about a phenomenon that has many researchers worried. Social isolation among men. I really don't think I dealt with it. I think I viewed it as sort of a circumstance
那项研究关注的是来自城市中最贫困、最艰难地区的男孩。这些研究共同描绘了一幅男性一生健康状况的生动图景。现在，你可以说这项研究显然是不完整的，因为它忽略了一半以上的人口。但它确实讲述了一个让许多研究人员感到担忧的现象：男性的社会孤立。我真的不认为我处理好了它。我想我把它看作是一种环境
rather than a problem, but there was also a part of me that realized I was alone. When we come back, we look at the profound loneliness of American men. Stay with us. stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. In recent decades there have been pervasive worries that Americans are spending less time with one another and that the ties that one's bound communities together have started to fray.
而不是一个问题，但我也意识到我确实很孤独。当我们回来时，我们将审视美国男性的深层孤独。请继续收听。请继续收听。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。近几十年来，人们普遍担心美国人花在彼此身上的时间越来越少，曾经将社区联系在一起的纽带已经开始磨损。
Back in 2000, the political scientistuthnum wrote about this idea in his book Bowling Alone. He described how many Americans were opting out of the civic and community organizations that their parents once joined. More recently, researchers have watched with growing concern as many of us spend increasing amounts of time hunched over our phones while ignoring those sitting across from us. There's another form of social isolation that's less talked about, one that disproportionately affects men. Men like Paul Kugelman. When Paul was a kid growing up in Union City, New Jersey, his parents had a simple rule. Go outside and play, come home with street lights, come on.
早在2000年，政治学家罗伯特·普特南在他的书《独自打保龄球》中写到了这个观点。他描述了许多美国人如何选择退出他们父母曾经加入的公民和社区组织。最近，研究人员怀着日益增长的担忧观察到，我们许多人花越来越多的时间盯着手机，却忽视了坐在对面的人。还有另一种较少被提及的社会孤立形式，它对男性的影响尤为严重。像保罗·库格尔曼这样的男人。当保罗在纽泽西州联合市长大时，他父母有一个简单的规则：出去玩，路灯亮了就回家。
Each weekday, Paul walked two and come home when the street lights come on. Each weekday, Paul walked two and from school with other kids in his neighborhood. Don and George and Joanne and Henry, John. When the kids got home, they dropped off their books and ran outside to play. We'd do whatever. It was a tag, a green leave you, a cafe to flag, football, whatever. It was just, it was friendship. You had people you could talk to, you were part of a community of your peers.
每个工作日，保罗和其他邻居孩子一起步行往返学校。唐、乔治、乔安妮、亨利、约翰。孩子们回家后，放下书包就跑出去玩。我们什么都玩。捉人游戏、旗帜橄榄球，什么都行。那只是友谊。你有可以交谈的人，你是同龄人社区的一部分。
It was nice. It was all so easy. Paul played pickup football in the vacant lot across the street from his home. He ran into his aunt Marie at the library. You just run into people all the time when you kind of knew everybody in the neighborhood. Then, when Paul was nine, he and his family moved 500 miles south to Martinsville, Virginia. Rural, Virginia didn't have all the amenities he was used to in New Jersey. Like the black and white cookies and coffee cake, he used to get at an iconic bakery.
那感觉真好。一切都那么简单。保罗在他家街对面的空地上玩自发组织的橄榄球。他在图书馆遇到他的玛丽阿姨。当你认识社区里的每个人时，你总是会遇到人。后来，保罗九岁时，他和家人搬到了500英里外的弗吉尼亚州马丁斯维尔。农村的弗吉尼亚州没有他在新泽西州习惯的那些便利设施。比如他在一家标志性面包店常买的黑白饼干和咖啡蛋糕。
Not only was this such thing as entenements, it was like, what do you mean by bagel? Paul missed his comfort foods, but that wasn't the only thing that gave him culture shock. It was my first few days in school and the teacher had a thick southern accent, and she was giving a spelling test. What I heard was Alpo, but she said Apple. But I heard Alpo, so I wrote Alpo, and these people concluded that I was a screaming idiot because I didn't understand how to spell Apple, and I was supposed to be this great student. And it kind of went downhill from there for a while.
不仅没有这些东西，甚至连“百吉饼”是什么意思都没人知道。保罗想念他熟悉的食物，但这并不是唯一让他感到文化冲击的事情。那是我在学校的前几天，老师有浓重的南方口音，她在进行拼写测试。我听到的是“Alpo”，但她说的是“Apple”。但我听到的是“Alpo”，所以我写了“Alpo”，这些人断定我是个彻头彻尾的白痴，因为我不知道怎么拼“Apple”，而我本该是个优等生。从那以后，情况就有点走下坡路了。
Paul's father was frequently relocated for work, after Virginia, to Delaware, then South Carolina. Each time the family moved, Paul had to navigate a new school and a new social world. Even though he didn't realize it at the time, he was gradually developing a strategy to cope with all the moves. I didn't really interact a whole lot with folks, because it just was like we're going to move again, so I didn't want the pain, I guess. Paul eventually went off to study at the Citadel,
保罗的父亲经常因为工作调动，从弗吉尼亚搬到特拉华州，然后是南卡罗来纳州。每次搬家，保罗都必须适应一所新学校和一个新的社交世界。尽管当时他没有意识到，但他正在逐渐形成一种应对所有搬迁的策略。我真的没有和人们进行太多互动，因为感觉就像我们又要搬走了，所以我不想承受那种痛苦，我想。保罗最终去南卡罗来纳州的城堡军事学院学习。
a military college in South Carolina. When he arrived, he was told that his classmates would become lifelong friends. But after they graduated, Paul found his former classmates were not very eager to stay in touch. Paul's life took its own trajectory. He got married, had a child, he got divorced. took its own trajectory. He got married, had a child, he got divorced. In his 30s, Paul went to law school and remarried. Just like before, he made acquaintances, but... I was in this place where, in my mind, everything was kind of transient. He didn't quite realize it, but his social world was shrinking. The acquaintances he made stayed acquaintances. He didn't have the time to develop these into real friendships. Family and work felt all-consuming.
当他到达时，他被告知他的同学将成为终身朋友。但毕业后，保罗发现他以前的同学并不太热衷于保持联系。保罗的生活走上了自己的轨道。他结婚、生子，然后离婚。走上了自己的轨道。他结婚、生子，然后离婚。30多岁时，保罗上了法学院并再婚。就像以前一样，他结识了一些熟人，但是……我处于这样一个境地，在我心里，一切都是短暂的。他没有完全意识到，但他的社交圈正在缩小。他结识的熟人依然只是熟人。他没有时间把这些发展成真正的友谊。家庭和工作让他感到精疲力竭。
In his mid-40s, Paul's second marriage fell apart. His ex-wife took the kids and moved several hours away. His mother had died young and Paul was estranged from his father. He talked to his daughter every day, but that routine ended too. Even though he was doing meaningful work as a lawyer, it wasn't enough. I guess lonely is the right word, it was a very lonely time. I don't remember specific triggers, it was just the sense of absolute isolation. I absolutely, it's too strong a word, I did go to work and I did have interactions at work and I cherished those.
40多岁时，保罗的第二次婚姻破裂了。他的前妻带着孩子搬到了几个小时车程外的地方。他的母亲早逝，保罗与父亲关系疏远。他每天都和女儿通话，但那种例行公事也结束了。尽管他作为一名律师从事着有意义的工作，但这还不够。我想“孤独”是正确的词，那是一段非常孤独的时光。我不记得具体的触发点，那只是一种绝对的孤立感。我绝对……“绝对”这个词太强烈了，我确实去上班，我在工作中确实有互动，我很珍惜那些互动。
But, you know, at the end of the day, it was just me. He drank heavily for a while. Then, he got into exercise. He eventually completed an Iron Man triathlon. But these distractions couldn't quite stamp out the fact that he was desperate for friendship for connection. So desperate that he turned to an inanimate object for comfort. I was in my apartment and one of the fixtures in the apartment was a post that runs Florida
但是，你知道，到头来，只有我一个人。他酗酒了一段时间。然后，他开始锻炼。他最终完成了铁人三项。但这些消遣无法完全消除他渴望友谊、渴望联系的事实。他渴望到转向一个无生命的物体寻求安慰。我在我的公寓里，公寓里的固定装置之一是一根从地板延伸到天花板的柱子，栏杆从那里延伸出来。那根柱子成了我的朋友，我会拥抱那根柱子。我会尽我所能地拥抱那根柱子，因为我在身体上得到了一些反馈。就在那一刻，我意识到我必须做点什么，因为当你到了需要拥抱一根柱子来感受你需要的东西时，如果那还不是警钟，那什么都不是了。保罗的童年提供了一个紧密社区的模式。他40多岁的生活与那个模式完全不同。回首往事，保罗说他忽视了社交圈正在缩小的警告信号。我真的不认为我坦诚地处理了它。我想我把它看作是一种环境
ceiling and a banister runs out of that. And the post became my friend, I would hug the post. I would hug the post for all it was worth because I was getting some kind of feedback physically. It was at that point I realized I have got to do something because when you get to the place where you need to hug a post to feel something that you need, that's not a wake-up call, nothing is. Paul's childhood offered a model of a close-knit community. His life in his 40s was nothing like that model. Looking back, Paul says he ignored the warning signs that his social world was shrinking. I really don't think I dealt with it candidly. I think I've viewed it as sort of a circumstance
而不是一个问题，就像重力一样。但我也有一部分意识到我很孤独。即使保罗鼓起勇气去接触其他人，他也发现自己碰到了社交规则的壁垒。他去向公寓楼的邻居介绍自己，却发现他们感到困惑多过友好。并不是他们说了什么特别的话，而是那种眼神，那种神情。就像，“你是个奇怪的家伙。一个51岁的男人为什么要敲我们的门告诉我们他住在隔壁？”
rather than a problem, it's kind of like gravity. But there is also a part of me that realized I was alone. Even when Paul got the courage to reach out to other people, he found himself budding up against social rules. He went to introduce himself to neighbors in his apartment building, but found them more bewildered than friendly. It's not like anything they said in particular, it's kind of the look, the countenance. Like, you're an odd dude. Why is a 51-year-old guy knocking on our door to tell us he lives next door?
对，部分原因是我认为被视为孤独或寂寞是有污名的。讽刺的是，保罗自己对那些和他处境相同的人并不宽容。很有趣，当我再次进入约会领域时，你知道，我是一个中年孤独的人，但我对那些和我属于同一群体的人非常警惕，因为，你知道，你这个年纪一个人在干什么？
Right, part of it is I think there's a stigma to being viewed as being alone or lonely. The irony was Paul himself wasn't very forgiving to people who were in the same boat that he was. It's funny like when I got out into the dating realm again, you know, I'm this middleaged alone person, but I'm very wary of people who are in the same group as I am because, you know, what are you doing at this age alone?
一次又一次，保罗被提醒，中年男人很难建立有意义的新友谊。在他开始约会后，他注意到他的女友金是如何轻松地开启对话并建立新联系的。她走到哪里都能交到朋友，而且没人会对一个女人主动去和男人或女人聊天感到惊讶。不仅仅是金。感觉男人和女人之间确实存在差异。
Over and over, Paul was reminded that it was hard for a middle-aged man to form meaningful new friendships. After he started dating, he noticed how his girlfriend Kim easily struck up conversations and made new connections. She can make friends anywhere she goes, and nobody bats an eye about a woman going up and just chatting either a guy or girl up. It wasn't just Kim. It felt like there was a difference between men and women.
有一次，他们在参加一个节日。金的朋友波莉不知从哪儿冒出来，召集了七八个人一起玩。我有一种感觉，如果我尝试那样做，那会像是，“好吧，那个令人毛骨悚然的老家伙是谁？”你知道吗？但我不知道，我认为存在，我认为男人确实存在一种污名。我不知道这是一种自我强加的东西，还是社会确实是这样看待它的。根据我的经验，我认为社会是这样看待它的，根据我的经验，我认为社会是这样看待它的，但我不能确定。
At one point, they were at a festival. Seemingly out of nowhere, Kim's friend Polly gathered together seven or eight people to hang out. And I had this feeling if I tried to do that, it would be like, okay, who's the creepy old dude? You know? But I don't, I think there is, I think there is a stigma for guys. And I don't know if it's just a, you know, a self-imposed thing or actually society views it that way. From my experience, I think society views it that way from my experience I think society views it that way, but I can't say for sure
他现在认识到，尽管很难，但接触他人是必不可少的。拒绝提供友谊或熟人关系的提议并不是一种拒绝。只是那个人还没准备好。保罗的故事在近几个月联系我们的许多其他男性身上得到了呼应。虽然每个故事的细节各不相同，但许多故事中都贯穿着相同的主题。这些男人觉得他们没有足够的朋友。即使他们想结交新朋友，他们也不知道该怎么做。我真的回顾过去15或20年的生活，我只看到亲密友谊的匮乏，我只是没有我曾经拥有的那种友谊。我结婚了，当我和妻子在一起时，有很多事情要做，但一天的时间不够
He now recognizes that even though it's hard reaching out to other people is essential a rejection of The extension of an offer of friendship or acquaintance hood isn't a rejection. It's just that that person's not ready Paul's story is echoed by many other men who reached out to us in recent months. Although each story is different in the details, the same themes run through many of them. These men felt they didn't have enough friends. Even when they wanted to make new friends, they didn't know how to do it. I really look back on the last 15 or 20 years of my life and I just see such a dirt of close friendships and just don't have the kind of friendships that I once did. I am married and when my wife and I are together there are things to do and not enough time in the day
和我们的朋友一起做这些事。当我和她分开超过一两天时，我就变成了一个隐士。许多已婚男性报告说他们的妻子组织了他们的社交活动。在最近一期的《Hidden Brain》中，心理学家伊莱·芬克尔解释了这种对一个人的过度依赖是如何成为一种新现象的。不久前，在美国，人们并不期望配偶同时是伴侣、爱人和最好的朋友。长期以来，婚姻为我们提供了一套相对有限的不同功能，随着时间的推移，我们堆积了越来越多的情感和心理功能，所以我们不再向亲密朋友
to do them with our friends. When she and I are apart from more than a day or two, I turn into a hermit. Many married men reported that their wives organized their social activities. In a recent episode of Hidden Brain, psychologist Eli Finkl explained how such over-aliance on one person is a new phenomenon. There was a time not long ago in the United States when people didn't expect their spouse to be partner and lover and best friend combined. Marriage for a long time served a set and relatively limited array of different functions for us, and over time we've piled more and more of these emotional and psychological functions, so instead of turning to our close friends
和其他亲戚寻求外出聚会、深层亲密披露，在越来越大的程度上，我们的配偶取代了我们过去寻求更广泛社交网络来帮助我们完成的许多事情。如果许多处于异性恋关系中的男性指望妻子成为他们社会联系的唯一提供者，这也给这些关系中的女性带来了巨大的压力。
and other relatives for nights out on the town, for deep intimate disclosure, to a larger and larger extent, our spouse has replaced a lot of what we used to look to our broader social network to help us do. If many men in heterosexual relationships count on wives to be their sole providers of social connection, this places enormous pressure on women in those relationships too.
当然，这一切都有例外。但总的来说，研究人员对男性日益严重的社会孤立以及这可能导致的结果感到担忧。有些男人不是通过参加铁人三项、酗酒或拥抱无生命物体来应对。他们采取了更极端的措施。我与朱莉·菲利普斯谈到了这一点。她是罗格斯大学的社会学教授。你在这里看的是哪个图表？呃，图二。
To be sure, there are exceptions to all of this. But overall, researchers are worried about increasing social isolation among men and where this might lead. Some men cope not by running an iron man or drinking or hugging an inanimate object. They take more drastic measures. I spoke to Julie Phillips about this. She's a sociology professor at Rutgers University. Which figure are you looking at here? Uh, figure two.
她带我看了几张显示不同年龄段男性自杀率的图表。这些比率从年轻人到老年人差异很大。然而，中年男性似乎面临着越来越大的风险。我们看到男性自杀率出现了相当急剧的上升，始于1999年。例如，在50至54岁的男性中，我们看到他们的自杀率上升了近50%。中年男性自杀率的上升令人担忧。这也是历史模式的逆转。与前几代人相比，自杀率的上升似乎开始得越来越早
She walked me through a couple of graphs that show the rate of suicide among men of different age groups. Those rates vary widely from the young to the very old. Increasingly, however, middle-aged men appear to be at growing risk. We saw a fairly sharp increase in suicide rates among men, beginning in 1999. So for example among men aged 50 to 54, we saw an increase of almost 50% in their suicide rate. The increase in the suicide rate among middle-aged men is troubling. It's also a reversal of historical patterns. Compared to earlier generations, the uptick in suicide seems to be starting earlier
尤其是对男性而言。对这一趋势的一种常见解释是它是由经济问题驱动的。朱莉认为情况更复杂。中年男性自杀率上升的趋势始于20世纪90年代末，远在2007年开始的大衰退之前。实际上，从1999年到2005年，中年人的增长仅限于那些没有受过大学教育的婴儿潮一代。但自2005年以来，它已经蔓延开来，确实是全面性的，我们没有看到教育程度带来的差异。朱莉对可能导致这些变化的原因有其他看法。
and earlier, especially for men. One common interpretation of this trend is that it's driven by economic problems. Julie thinks it's more complicated. The trend of rising suicide rates among middle-aged men began in the late 1990s, well before the Great Recession that started in 2007. Actually, from 1999 to 2005, the increases among the middle age were really confined to those boomers who did not have a college education. But since 2005, it has now subordinate out, it's really been across the board, we don't see these differences by education. Julie has other ideas about what might be driving these changes.
人们的社会支持减少了。他们更有可能远离家人居住。许多人选择不结婚。许多人正在离婚。即使我们选择与他人联系，我们通常也不是面对面进行的。我还想谈谈我们互动的方式以及它是如何改变的。当然，在过去15、20年左右，我知道社交媒体的兴起，面对面接触减少，娱乐变得更加私密。
People have fewer social supports. They're more likely to live far away from family. Many are opting out of marriage. Many are getting divorced. Even when we choose to connect with others, we're often not doing it in person. I also wanted to just about the ways in which we interact and how that has changed. Certainly over the past 15, 20 years or so, I knew the rise of social media, less face-to-face contact, entertainment has become more private.
例如，我们在家看电影，而不是去电影院。这可能也产生了影响，可能导致了孤独感，这种社会孤立也可能导致了一些上升的比率。同样，社会孤立的代价不仅仅是情感上的。一项对近150项研究的分析发现，拥有稳固社会关系的人的死亡风险比那些联系较弱的人低约50%。朱莉安·霍尔特-伦斯塔德和她的合著者得出结论，那些社会关系较弱的人
We watch a movie at home, rather than going to a theater, for example. That may also be having it, maybe contributing to feelings of isolation, social isolation that could also be producing some of these rising rates. Again, the toll of social isolation is ingest emotional. An analysis of nearly 150 studies has found that people with strong social relationships had about a 50% lower mortality risk than those with weaker ties. Julian Holtlunstad and her co-authors concluded that those with weaker social relationships
比身体不活动或肥胖的人有更大的死亡风险。让我换个说法。花时间建立和培养你的友谊可能和你饮食均衡、锻炼一样对你的健康很重要。当我们回来时，我们将审视这个问题的文化根源。这些是，你知道，拥有令人难以置信的情感和社会能力的人类，而我们作为一个文化，完全试图把这些从他们身上抹去，我们忽视了它。
had a greater risk of death than people who were physically inactive or obese. Let me put that another way. Spending time, time building and nurturing your friendships might be just as important to your health as eating right and exercising. When we come back, we look at the cultural roots of this problem. These are, you know, human beings with unbelievable, emotional and social capacity, and we as a culture just completely try to zip it out of them, and we ignore it.
请继续收听。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们正在探索社会孤立对我们一生的影响。特别是，我们正在关注那些在结交和维持友谊方面往往比女性更困难的男性。经济力量当然在侵蚀社会纽带方面发挥了作用，但心理学家内奥比·韦认为，男性孤独的根源更深。她认为它们主要是文化性的，根植于
Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're exploring the effects of social isolation over the course of our lives. In particular, we're looking at men who tend to have a harder time than women when it comes to making and maintaining friendships. Economic forces certainly play a role in eroding social ties, but psychologists, Nairobi, Wei, thinks that the roots of loneliness among men go deeper. She thinks they are primarily cultural, embedded,
扭曲的男子气概观念。20世纪80年代末，内奥比在波士顿的一所高中担任辅导员。她期望学校里的男孩谈论他们的课程、家庭困难、暴力和社区。但他们谈论最多的是他们的友谊，试图寻找好的友谊，以及被学校里的其他男孩伤害的感觉。起初，她很惊讶。当我开始听到男孩们谈论这些时，起初我很纳闷，为什么他们听起来不像我以为他们会听起来的那样。
and twisted ideas of what it takes to be a man. In the late 1980s, Nairobi worked as a counselor at a high school in Boston. She expected the boys in her school to talk about their classes, difficulties with family, violence, and the neighborhood. What they were mostly talking about is their friendships and trying to find good friendships and feeling hurt by other boys in the school. At first, she was surprised. When I started to hear boys, it was at first wondering why they weren't sounding like the boys I thought they were going to sound like.
所以本质上，为什么他们听起来不像我心目中对他们的刻板印象，无论是作为男孩还是工人阶级男孩，还是有色人种男孩等等。我以为他们谈论很多关于，你知道，友谊，他们在80年代末听起来就像，引用我的话，像女孩。她想知道男孩们出了什么问题，而不是刻板印象出了什么问题。这就是刻板印象的运作方式。我们知道它们对自己不适用，但我们不知何故认为它们对其他人适用。当内奥比研究这个问题时，她发现其他文化中的男性和美国其他时代的男性在成年后发展亲密友谊完全没有问题。而她认识的那些男人，至少在他们生命中的某个时刻，
And so essentially, it was why didn't they sound like the stereotypes that I had of them, whether as boys or as working class boys it's boys of color, etc. I was thinking they were talking a lot about, you know, friendships, they sounded like quote unquote in my head in the late 80s, like girls. She wanted to know what was wrong with the boys, not what was wrong with a stereotype. That's how stereotypes work. We know that they're not true for ourselves, but we somehow think they're true for other people. As Nairobi studied the issue, she discovered that men in other cultures and American men in other times had no problem developing clothes, intimate friendships, well into adulthood. And the men she knew, at least at one point in
在公开表达情感方面完全没有问题。我实际上有非常非常清晰的记忆，我的兄弟们也有类似的友谊。内奥比记得有一次她坐在父母家楼上，能听到她弟弟和他的朋友们在外面。他在后院和他的篮球队友聊天。其中一个人对组里的另一个人说了刻薄的话。他们四个人花了一个小时处理围绕这个男孩对其他男孩的刻薄行为的情绪。
their lives, had no problem being deeply and openly emotional. I actually had very, very clear memories of my brothers having similar kinds of friendships. Nairobi remembers a time when she was sitting upstairs in her parents' house, and she could hear her younger brother and his friends outside. He was out in the backyard talking with his basketball teammates. One of the guys had said something mean to one of the other guys in the group. And the four of them were processing their feelings around this mean behavior by one of the boys, towards the other boys.
这些都是四个看起来很强硬的篮球运动员，运动型、高中里很酷的孩子。他们都坐在那里大约一个小时，互相处理这些情绪。然后她记得她另一个兄弟在青春期前与他最好的朋友闹翻了。我记得我兄弟因为友谊那种即时的、戏剧性的破裂而感到的巨大悲伤。所有这些开始改变内奥比倾听的方式。我意识到它就在我身边，很多男孩，我的兄弟，我的朋友，各种各样的男孩和年轻人都谈论这种渴望，或者拥有这些亲密友谊，或者渴望它。内奥比在攻读博士学位时带着这些观察结果。
And these were four tough looking basketball players, athletic, cool kids in the high school. And they were all sitting there for about an hour processing these feelings with each other. Then she remembered how her other brother had a falling out with his best friend when he was a preteen. I remember the enormous sadness of my brother around that sort of immediate sort of dramatic departure of a friendship. All this started to change how Niobe listened. I realized it was all around me that lots of boys, my brothers, my friends, my all sorts of boys and young men were talking about this desire or having these close friendships or desiring it. Nairobi took these observations with her as she went out to get a PhD.
她最终成为了纽约大学的发展心理学家。从那时起，她采访了数百名男孩，经常年复一年地回访同样的孩子。绝大多数人告诉她像这样的话，这是她从一个名叫贾斯汀的15岁男孩那里听到的。我们让青少年演员朗读了这些引语。“我最好的朋友和我彼此相爱。就是这样。你拥有这种如此深厚的东西，它就在你内心。你无法解释它。它只是一种东西，你知道，那个人就是那个人。这就是我们友谊中唯一重要的东西。我想在生活中，有时，两个人真的、真的能理解彼此，并且真的
She eventually became a developmental psychologist at NYU. She's interviewed hundreds of boys since then, often circling back to the same kids year after year. The overwhelming majority have told her things like this, which she heard from a 15-year-old named Justin. We had teenage actors read the quotes. My best friend and I love each other. That's it. You have this thing that is so deep it's within you. You can't explain it. It's just a thing that, you know, that that person is that person. And that's all that should be important in our friendship. I guess in life sometimes, two people can really, really understand each other and really
对彼此有信任、尊重和爱。它就是发生了。这就像人性。”她从一个16岁男孩那里听到了关于亲密朋友重要性的看法。“我的意思是，如果你只有母亲和父母可以交谈，那么你就会把所有这些想法都憋在心里
have a trust respect and love for each other. It just happens. It's like human nature. She heard this about the importance of close friends from a 16 year old. I mean, if you just have your mother and your parents to talk to, then you're just gonna have all these ideas bottled up
然后你就会发疯，因为你无法表达自己。”但随着男孩长大，发生了一些变化。他们变得更难表达温柔和脆弱。那些谈论他们如何爱最好的朋友，或者没有他们就会发疯的男孩，开始听起来更像青少年男孩的刻板印象。那些不想和任何感性事物有任何关系的人。有些男孩会表现出一种“我不在乎，无所谓，你知道，随便”的态度。但他们说“我不在乎”的次数太多了，以至于你能感觉到他们其实非常在乎。一些大一点的男孩确实和内奥比谈论了悲伤
and you're just gonna go wacko because you can't express yourself. But as a boy's called older, something happened. It became harder for them to express tenderness and vulnerability. Boys who had talked about how they loved their best friend, or would go wacko without them, began to sound more like a stereotype of teenage boys. The ones who didn't want to have anything to do were touchy-feely stuff. Some of the boys go into sort of, I don't care, it doesn't matter, you know, whatever. But they say, I don't care so many times that you sense exactly that they do very much care. Some of the older boys did talk to Nairobi about the sadness
他们对逐渐消失的友谊感到悲伤。一名高中生描述了他的友谊自高一以来是如何改变的。“我和我最好的朋友的友谊正在淡化，但我说它还在那里。所以我的意思是，它还在那里，因为我们仍然一起做事情，但只是偶尔。这很悲伤，因为他只住在我隔壁一个街区，但我和他一起做事情的机会比我和住得更远的人一起做事情的机会还要少。所以我感觉，就像一个DJ，你只是推了交叉推子，开始慢慢地淡化它，现在我感觉交叉淡化已经进行了一半。”这就是男孩的语言。
they felt at disappearing friendships. A high school senior described how his friendships have changed since freshman year. My friendship with my best friend is fading, but I'm saying it's still there. So I mean, it's still there because we still do stuff together, but only once in a while. It's sad because he lives only one block away from me, and I get to do stuff with him less than I get to do stuff for people who are way further. So I'm like, it's like a DJ, you just cross-fader and started fading it slowly and slowly, and now I'm like halfway through the cross-fade. This is the language of boys.
我的意思是，这简直是关于谈论他们的感受以及他们周围关系世界中正在发生的事情的非常美丽的语言。所以观点是，男孩们不仅仅是在表达情感。他们实际上是以一种美丽的、你知道，清晰的方式解读世界，这正是他们的刻板印象认为他们无法做到的。男孩比女孩情感更少的刻板印象在内奥比采访男孩时并不成立。这些是拥有令人难以置信的情感和社会能力的人类，而我们作为一个文化，完全试图把这些从他们身上抹去，
I mean, this is just remarkably beautiful language about talking about how they're feeling and what's happening in the relational world around them. So the idea is that boys aren't just being emotional. They're actually reading the world in a beautiful, you know, articulate way, which is exactly how their stereotype not to be able to do. The stereotype that boys are less emotional than girls doesn't hold up when Nairobi interviews boys. These are human beings with unbelievable emotional and social capacity and we as a culture just completely try to zip it out of them,
我们忽视了它。内奥比对男孩为什么难以维持亲密纽带有一个解释。这种挣扎的原因其实很简单，那就是美国的男子气概，以及男性规范和男性期望，使亲密友谊变成了一种“娘娘腔”或“同性恋”的事情，而不是简单的人类的事情。所以当男孩长大并进入成年期
and we ignore it. NIOB has an explanation for why boys have trouble maintaining close bonds with one another. The reason for that struggle really is quite simple, which is that it's American masculinity, and masculine norms, and masculine expectations, that make close friendships into a girly gay thing rather than simply a human thing. So as boys grow older and and enter manhood
他们开始被这种期望所淹没，即不知何故他们必须，你知道，独自一人。他们不能依赖他人，他们必须独自一人，他们不能依赖他人，他们必须完全独立，不知何故，在一种非常崇尚超男子气概的文化中，对与其他男孩亲密的渴望是有问题的。这种超男子气概，男孩们很快且无意识地就学会了。有一个评论是内奥比无法忘记的。“你知道，如果我是个女孩可能会很好，因为我就不必那么压抑情感了。”有一个评论是内奥比无法忘记的。那一句引语捕捉到了我交谈过的许多男孩的心声。甚至连父母也相信，如果他们的十几岁男孩表现得敏感和脆弱，那是值得担忧的事情。
they begin to be overwhelmed with this expectation that somehow they have to be you know on their own. They can't depend on others they have to be on their own, they can't depend on others, they have to be fully independent, that somehow the desire for intimacy with other boys is problematic in a culture that's very hyper-masculine. This hyper-masculinity, boys pick it up quickly and unconsciously. There's one comment that Niobe can't forget. You know, it might be nice to be a girl because I wouldn't have to be so emotionalist. There's one comment that Niobe can't forget. That one quote just captured so many of the boys I've spoken with. Even parents buy into the idea that there's something to be concerned about if their teenage boys appear sensitive and vulnerable.
他们开始被这种期望所淹没，认为自己必须独立，不能依赖他人，必须完全自立。在一种极度崇尚阳刚之气的文化中，他们渴望与其他男孩建立亲密关系，却觉得这成了一个问题。这种过度阳刚的文化，男孩们很快就会在潜意识里习得。尼奥比有一句评论至今难忘：你知道，如果我是个女孩可能会更好，因为我就不必表现得那么情绪化了。这句话精准地概括了许多我交谈过的男孩的心声。甚至连父母也会陷入一种误区，认为如果他们的青春期儿子表现得敏感脆弱，就是一件值得担忧的事情。
I think parents sometimes even get anxious when their boys sound like this. So even when you hear parents talking about their kids being very sensitive, it's often times with with their sons there's oftentimes an embarrassment about it. And parents certainly aren't you know judging their sons in the same ways but parents are part of the culture just like everybody else. Niobe has had parents come to her and say you know I think my son is gay and I'll say, oh, okay, so, you know, what makes you think that? And they'll say, well, you know, he's very sensitive. And, you know, that to me is, as depressing as the comment about it might be nice to be a girl, because then,
我认为父母有时甚至会因为男孩表现出这种样子而感到焦虑。所以，即使当你听到父母谈论他们的孩子非常敏感时，通常情况下，对于他们的儿子，他们往往会感到尴尬。父母当然不会像其他人那样评判自己的儿子，但父母和所有人一样，都是文化的一部分。妮奥比（Niobe）曾遇到过父母来找她说：你知道，我觉得我儿子是同性恋。我会说，哦，好的，那么，是什么让你这么认为呢？他们会说，嗯，你知道，他非常敏感。对我来说，这和那种说“要是能当个女孩就好了”的评论一样令人沮丧，因为那样的话，
you know, you wouldn't have to be emotionless, because the idea is that, first of all, of course, being gay is as glorious as wonderful as being straight, but you know, the fact that they're equating sexuality with being sensitive has nothing to do with sexuality. Naomi doesn't ask the boys she interviews about their sexual orientation. Some of them might, indeed, be gay, but she thinks that boys of all sexual orientations find themselves in straight jackets that tell them that they's something wrong if they appear excessively emotional. To put this another way, the problem of hypermasculinity doesn't just affect straight boys who are worried about appearing gay.
你知道，你就不用表现得毫无感情了。因为这种观念是，首先，当然，同性恋和异性恋一样光荣、一样美好，但你知道，他们把性取向与敏感等同起来，这与性取向毫无关系。娜奥米（Naomi）并没有询问她采访的男孩关于他们的性取向。他们中有些人确实可能是同性恋，但她认为，无论什么性取向的男孩，都发现自己被困在一种紧身衣里，这种紧身衣告诉他们，如果表现得过于情绪化，就是有什么不对劲。换句话说，过度男性化的问题不仅仅影响那些担心被看作同性恋的异性恋男孩。
The model of the tough guy who doesn't need others who can move through the world without being bruised by it. This model affects all boys. When boys lose their close friendships, there's more at stake than sleepovers and having someone to sit next to on the way to school. Niobe thinks there are consequences for mental health. I just don't think it's just coincidental that at the very time you hear their language, the love in their language, the emotional attunement in their language, diminish and the anger, the frustration, the I don't care of voice comes into their stories is the exact same time that the suicide rate increases.
那种不需要他人、可以在世界上行走而不受伤害的硬汉模式。这种模式影响着所有的男孩。当男孩失去亲密的友谊时，所失去的不仅仅是留宿和上学路上有人陪伴。妮奥比认为这对心理健康有影响。我只是觉得，在你们听到他们的语言、语言中的爱、语言中的情感协调减少，而愤怒、挫折、那种“我不在乎”的声音进入他们的故事时，自杀率正好在同一时间上升，这绝非巧合。
There is no hard evidence that the decline of friendships among adolescent boys is responsible for suicide, but Nairobi is worried by a correlation. As boys' friendships start to weaken, their diary entries start to reveal mental health problems. Nairobi's concern led her to team up with another professor and a middle school teacher. The idea was to help boys connect more deeply with people they cared about. How? Asking them to conduct in-depth interviews with their loved ones. They started the program at an all-boys school and have since expanded it to other schools. At the top of the show, we heard from two 12-year-olds
虽然没有确凿证据表明青少年男孩友谊的减少是导致自杀的原因，但内罗毕（Nairobi）对这种相关性感到担忧。随着男孩们的友谊开始减弱，他们的日记开始揭示出心理健康问题。内罗毕的担忧促使她与另一位教授和一名中学老师合作。这个想法是为了帮助男孩们与他们在乎的人建立更深层的联系。怎么做？让他们对所爱的人进行深度访谈。他们在全男校开始了该项目，并已扩展到其他学校。在节目开始时，我们听到了两位12岁男孩的声音，
at one school. My producer, Raina Cohen, talked to their classmates. So as you get older, it kind of seems like the girls drift closer to the girls and the boys drift closer to the boys Because you're going through something that's very similar as the other boys in your grade and the girls are going through something very similar Has the girls in their grades? So you kind of group up with someone you have someone in common So friendships as we get older and we hit puberty friendships, especially with the other opposite gender They can get altered in a way.
在其中一所学校。我的制片人雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）采访了他们的同学。随着年龄增长，女孩似乎更倾向于和女孩在一起，男孩更倾向于和男孩在一起。因为你正在经历和你年级里其他男孩非常相似的事情，而女孩们也在经历和她们年级里女孩非常相似的事情。所以你们会和有共同点的人聚在一起。因此，随着我们长大并进入青春期，友谊，尤其是与异性之间的友谊，可能会以某种方式发生改变。
They can become more intimate or romantic. To me, it's kind of scary, because I'm not really ready for that yet. In some cases, like boys can just be friends with boys and not talk about emotional things. But if you're closer friends with that boy, then I think you feel more comfortable talking about what's going on emotionally with you. Then you would be with one of your not-as-close friends. So I think it's not true that boys don't talk to their friends about personal things.
它们可能会变得更加亲密或浪漫。对我来说，这有点可怕，因为我还没准备好。在某些情况下，男孩可以只是和男孩做朋友，而不谈论情感问题。但如果你和那个男孩是更亲密的朋友，那么我认为你会更自在地谈论你情感上的事情。这会比你和那些不那么亲密的朋友谈论时更自在。所以我认为男孩不和朋友谈论个人私事是不对的。
It's actually easier to talk about personal things with your friends and your parents because they fully or mostly understand what you're going through because they're probably going through something similar like that too. But you wouldn't know that based on the way that boys are portrayed in TV shows and movies. There's more of a depth to a real relationship between friends in my age. The boys themselves have theories about what's going on. I mean, I think boys can be emotional if they want to,
实际上，和朋友谈论私事比和父母谈论更容易，因为他们完全或大部分理解你正在经历的事情，因为他们可能也在经历类似的事情。但你无法从电视节目和电影中对男孩的刻画中了解到这一点。在我这个年龄，朋友之间真正的关系更有深度。男孩们自己对正在发生的事情也有理论。我的意思是，我认为男孩如果想的话是可以有情绪的，
but I don't think they do. I think they've just been influenced by the past of the society before that boys don't share emotions and I think that's just because they've been influenced. Already some of these kids can see what's ahead. The only acceptable place to express emotion isn't the context of a romantic relationship and you're supposed to allow those relationships to suck up all the oxygen you once gave to your friendships. When you get a girlfriend, like you have to spend a lot of time with her or if you get a boyfriend you have to spend a lot of time with him.
但我认为他们并没有这样做。我认为他们只是受到了过去社会的影响，认为男孩不应该分享情绪，我认为这只是因为他们受到了影响。这些孩子中已经有些人能预见到未来。唯一可以表达情绪的被接受的场合是浪漫关系，而你被要求让这些关系吸走你曾经给予友谊的所有氧气。当你有了女朋友，你必须花很多时间陪她，或者如果你有了男朋友，你必须花很多时间陪他。
So like you kind of spend more time with them than you do with your best friends and then they might get jealous and react. Of course this is exactly the kind of thinking that, in 30 or 40 years, leaves middle-aged men bereft of social connection when their marriages fall apart or spouse dies. Reina asked two boys about their friendship. Do you ever say anything like, I love you or you're important to me or you're looking at me dumbfounded. I don't say I love you in well a gay way I maybe I say oh man I love you bro like a you're my you're my
所以你花在他们身上的时间比花在最好的朋友身上的时间多，然后他们可能会嫉妒并做出反应。当然，这正是那种在30或40年后，当婚姻破裂或配偶去世时，让中年男人失去社会联系的思维方式。雷娜问了两个男孩关于他们友谊的问题。你们会说“我爱你”或者“你对我来说很重要”之类的话吗？你们看着我一脸茫然。我不会以那种同性恋的方式说“我爱你”，我可能会说，哦伙计，我爱你兄弟，就像你是我的，你是我的
dude you're important to me but now romance romance I think yes. Um yeah um he knows that he's very important to me. So we don't like... I mean, not really. Or sometimes we say, you're my man or like, I got you. And I love you bro, like we hug, but we don't go on full on holding hands. The boys we heard from in New York are already learning the lesson that there are certain kinds of friendship between men
哥们，你对我来说很重要，但浪漫，浪漫的话，我想是的。嗯，是的，嗯，他知道他对我来说非常重要。所以我们不会……我的意思是，并不是真的。或者有时我们会说，你是我的好兄弟，或者说，我罩着你。我爱你兄弟，我们会拥抱，但我们不会完全手牵手。我们在纽约听到的男孩们已经学到了一个教训，即男人之间存在某些种类的友谊
that society deems acceptable. One is the bromance. Men can say, I love you, they can hug each other. But the bromance plot, at least as Hollywood shows it, involves supercharged testosterone, not intimacy. If there's any flash of tenderness, it comes after 90 minutes of hijinks, binge drinking, and sexual conquest.
是社会认为可以接受的。一种是“兄弟情”（bromance）。男人可以说“我爱你”，他们可以拥抱。但“兄弟情”的情节，至少在好莱坞电影中，涉及的是超强的睾丸激素，而不是亲密感。如果有一丝温柔的闪现，那也是在90分钟的胡闹、狂饮和性征服之后。
Like in the movie, Superman. After a wild party, two teenage friends open up to each other. They're exhausted and cold up in sleeping bags. I keep late. I owe you so... I'm cared. I love you. I love you, man. I love you. I love you. I'm not you and embarrassed to say I just... I love you. I'm not even embarrassed to say. I just... I love you. I'm not embarrassed. I love you. I love you.
就像电影《超人》里那样。在一次疯狂的派对后，两个十几岁的朋友向对方敞开心扉。他们筋疲力尽，在睡袋里感到寒冷。我一直很晚。我欠你的，所以……我很在乎。我爱你。我爱你，伙计。我爱你。我爱你。我不，我不尴尬说出来，我只是……我爱你。我甚至不尴尬说出来。我只是……我爱你。我不尴尬。我爱你。我爱你。
Bromances are not evidence that men have transcended homophobia. They're away from men to dabble in emotional connection while telegraphing to the world that they're absolutely not, not even a little bit, gay. Nairobi says some big changes need to happen for emotional 12-year-old boys to grow into emotional 42-year-olds. How do we as a culture change the culture to normalize, to humanize this fundamental human need and capacity of reading the human world and engaging with it and having quality relationships. We can change it because we already know that through gay marriage, we now accept gay marriage
“兄弟情”并不能证明男人已经超越了恐同心理。这只是男人涉足情感联系的一种方式，同时向世界传达他们绝对不是，哪怕一点点也不是同性恋。内罗毕说，为了让12岁感性的男孩成长为42岁感性的男人，需要发生一些重大变化。我们作为一个文化，如何改变这种文化以正常化、人性化这种解读人类世界、参与其中并拥有高质量关系的基本人类需求和能力？我们可以改变它，因为我们已经知道，通过同性婚姻，我们现在接受了同性婚姻
as a culture. We can change anything we want to change. Men's fear of appearing gay or feminine isn't the only reason many of us end up lonely. Both men and women are plagued by a bias that pushes us towards isolation rather than connection. Nick Eppley regularly writes the Chicago Metro system. He was on the train one day when he noticed something puzzling. We happen to be one of the most social species on the planet who seems to get a lot of happiness and satisfaction from our connections with others and yet
作为一种文化。我们可以改变任何我们想改变的东西。男人害怕被看作同性恋或女性化并不是我们许多人最终感到孤独的唯一原因。男人和女人都受到一种偏见的困扰，这种偏见将我们推向孤立而不是联系。尼克·埃普利（Nick Eppley）经常乘坐芝加哥地铁系统。有一天他在火车上时，注意到了一些令人困惑的事情。我们恰好是这个星球上最善于社交的物种之一，似乎从与他人的联系中获得了许多快乐和满足，然而
every morning on the train and over and over again in public spaces where I'd be out and about, I would see people standing cheek to jaw well next to each other or sitting cheek to jaw well next to each other and ignoring each other. Nick is a behavioral science professor at the University of Chicago Boots School of Business. He started thinking about this odd behavior. Why do we ignore one another? One possibility is that strangers in fact are unpleasant. We don't know them and striking up a conversation would be less pleasant than sitting there in solitude so people are maximizing their well-being by sitting on the train or maybe in a cab or on a
每天早上在火车上，以及在公共场所，我一次又一次地看到人们脸贴着脸站在彼此旁边，或者脸贴着脸坐在彼此旁边，却无视对方。尼克是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的行为科学教授。他开始思考这种奇怪的行为。为什么我们无视彼此？一种可能性是陌生人实际上是不愉快的。我们不认识他们，开始交谈会比坐在那里孤独地待着更不愉快，所以人们通过坐在火车上，或者可能在出租车里，或者在
bus or in a waiting room and ignoring each other. That's possible. The other possibility is that we actually underestimate the benefits that come from social engagement. That we think we'd be happier sitting in solitude and in fact we're just wrong about that. Nick and his co-author, Julianna Schroder, decided to figure out what was going on. They ran an experiment that involved commuters. Volunteers were assigned to one of three conditions, engage with the people around them, sit in solitude, or act as they normally would on their commute. People predicted that they would be the least happy if they had to engage with other people on the train. They were sure that what would make them happy was to be simply left alone.
公共汽车或候诊室里无视彼此来最大化他们的幸福感。这有可能。另一种可能性是我们实际上低估了社会参与带来的好处。我们认为坐在孤独中会更快乐，而事实上我们对此是错误的。尼克和他的合著者朱莉安娜·施罗德（Julianna Schroder）决定弄清楚发生了什么。他们进行了一项涉及通勤者的实验。志愿者被分配到三种情况之一：与周围的人互动，独自坐着，或者像往常一样通勤。人们预测，如果他们必须在火车上与其他人互动，他们会最不快乐。他们确信能让他们快乐的是简单地被单独留下。
But that's not what the study found. People reported being happier, less sad, and having a more pleasant commute when they connected with the person sitting next to them, than when we randomly assigned them to a condition where they were asked to sit in solitude. People's perception that their fellow commuters wanted to be left alone didn't match reality. What was happening was that volunteers thought People's perception that their fellow commuters wanted to be left alone didn't match reality. What was happening was that volunteers thought that others were less interested in talking to them than they actually were.
但研究结果并非如此。与被随机分配到独自坐着的情况相比，当人们与坐在旁边的人建立联系时，他们报告说更快乐、更少悲伤，并且通勤过程更愉快。人们认为他们的通勤同伴想被单独留下的看法与现实不符。发生的情况是，志愿者认为其他人对与他们交谈的兴趣比实际情况要低。
In one study, volunteers were asked, what percentage of people on the train would be interested in talking to you, or would be willing to talk to you if you tried. They estimated fewer than 50% of people would. As far as we can tell, the actual percentage of people who would be willing to talk to you is much closer to 100%. This distorted belief keeps us and the strangers around us from connecting with one another,
在一项研究中，志愿者被问到：如果你尝试的话，火车上有百分之多少的人会有兴趣和你交谈，或者愿意和你交谈？他们估计不到50%的人会愿意。据我们所知，实际上愿意和你交谈的人的百分比更接近100%。这种扭曲的信念阻止了我们和周围的陌生人建立联系，
opening a conversation, making small talk. Hey, I like those pants, those are good-looking shoes. What do you think of the weather today? How long have you been riding this train? Nick says there are two steps to having a pleasant conversation, getting it started and keeping it going. And what we find in our data is that the barrier seems to be in the first of those things. It's not that people anticipate that having a conversation once it gets going will be unpleasant.
开启对话，进行闲聊。嘿，我喜欢那条裤子，那双鞋很好看。你觉得今天的天气怎么样？你坐这趟火车多久了？尼克说，进行愉快的谈话有两个步骤：开始谈话和保持谈话。我们在数据中发现，障碍似乎在于第一步。并不是人们预料到一旦谈话开始就会不愉快。
They think that'll be okay. Instead, the barrier seems to come earlier. There's anxiety about actually starting the conversation, engaging in the conversation. And that's what seems to lead people to predict that it's going to be unpleasant. Nick has an analogy. It's like climbing up a steep hill.
他们认为那会没问题。相反，障碍似乎来得更早。对于真正开始谈话、参与谈话存在焦虑。而这似乎导致人们预测谈话会不愉快。尼克有一个类比。这就像爬上一座陡峭的山。
You've got to get over that initial speed bump at the top and then after that it seems to go pretty smoothly but if you don't get over that first initial bump you'll never get started. Of course not everyone has the same freedom to chat with strangers in the way Nick suggests. Agenda, race, appearance and many other factors affect how people view us. In some context it can be dangerous to start a conversation with a stranger. But what's clear from many of the messages we receive from hidden brain listeners is that the desire for connection is deep and in many cases, unfulfilled. Loneliness and social isolation has become more and more part of my daily life.
你必须越过顶部的初始减速带，然后在那之后一切似乎进行得相当顺利，但如果你没有越过第一个初始障碍，你就永远无法开始。当然，并不是每个人都有同样的自由以尼克建议的方式与陌生人聊天。性别、种族、外貌和许多其他因素影响着人们如何看待我们。在某些情况下，与陌生人开始谈话可能是危险的。但从我们收到的许多“隐藏大脑”（Hidden Brain）听众的留言中可以清楚地看出，对联系的渴望是深刻的，在许多情况下，是未被满足的。孤独和社会孤立已经越来越多地成为我日常生活的一部分。
It's harder to make friends, it's harder to find situations that I enjoy being in. I have two or three friends that I've known since we were all teenagers. And other than that, if my wife were in a round, I would be hard pressed to have close friends other than those from a long time ago. We have perhaps more of a reason to turn to people and to wean on those friendships and those relationships to give us strength, but they're often not there in the way that they are for women or they were, you know, when we were hanging out with our friends and our friends. Think how much better life could be if we could just admit these things to someone we care about, not just to a voicemail inbox. If we could be okay with being vulnerable, with being dependent on someone who's not a spouse, if we didn't look suspiciously at older men who are friendly, or shame boys who talk about their love for their friends,
交朋友更难了，找到我喜欢待的环境也更难了。我有两三个从青少年时期就认识的朋友。除此之外，如果我妻子不在身边，除了那些很久以前的朋友，我很难有亲密的朋友。我们或许更有理由转向他人，并依靠那些友谊和关系来给我们力量，但它们往往不像对女性那样，或者不像我们以前和朋友们在一起时那样存在。想想如果我们能向在乎的人承认这些事情，而不是只对着语音信箱，生活会变得多好。如果我们能接受脆弱，接受依赖一个非配偶的人，如果我们不以怀疑的眼光看待友好的老年男性，或者羞辱谈论对朋友之爱的男孩，
if we expected friendships to endure, even as our lives change, so they don't have to fade to silence. This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyer. Our staff includes Jenny Schmidt, Path Shal, Laura Correll and Thomas Liu. We had original music composed by Ramteen Arableui. Special thanks to Emil and Finn Bobean who read the quotes you heard in the show. A run song here or this week is Gina Voskov. She's a teacher at the United Nations International School. She helped us arrange interviews with a group of seventh and eighth grade boys. She kindly managed a long string of emails as she coordinated between our producer, the students, and their parents.
如果我们期望友谊能够持久，即使我们的生活发生了变化，这样它们就不必在沉默中消逝。本集由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博耶（Tara Boyer）编辑。我们的工作人员包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕斯·沙尔（Path Shal）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。我们有由拉姆廷·阿拉布伊（Ramteen Arableui）创作的原创音乐。特别感谢埃米尔（Emil）和芬恩·博比恩（Finn Bobean）朗读了你在节目中听到的引语。本周的运行歌曲是吉娜·沃斯科夫（Gina Voskov）。她是联合国国际学校的一名老师。她帮助我们安排了与一群七八年级男孩的采访。她在协调我们的制片人、学生和家长之间的一长串电子邮件时给予了友好的管理。
Thank you, Gina. If you like this show, here's an important thing you can do for us, and an important thing you can do for yourself. Tell one friend about our show and consider striking up a conversation with a stranger this week. If you can't think of anything else to say, ask them, hey, do you listen to Hidden Brain? Tell us what happens next on Facebook or Twitter. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，吉娜。如果你喜欢这个节目，这里有一件你可以为我们做的重要事情，也是一件你可以为你自己做的重要事情。告诉一位朋友我们的节目，并考虑在本周与一位陌生人交谈。如果你想不出别的话说，问问他们：嘿，你听“隐藏大脑”吗？在Facebook或Twitter上告诉我们接下来发生了什么。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是NPR。你你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。